by the way this played out last night
Chris Harrison the host of the bachelor
man of his word said that he was going
to drop passion bucket and he's talking
to a former couple on The Bachelor and
this is what Chris had to say if you
play the odds this has happened once
before a hundred percent success rate
for this happening it's good to see that
your passion bucket is still full now
our audience loved it
I think the female audience was like
passion bucket ooh like what's that
Chris Harrison joins us now Chris what
was the reaction to passion bucket one
I'll probably never get a date now again
because you know no normal man says the
word passion bucket so thank you for
that second of all I don't know if you
guys realize how many fans you have I
think Dan nation and bachelor nation are
very much in a line because as I was
walking off the set last night I had at
least 10 people come up to me and
mention the fact that I dropped passion
bucket on the show so apparently
fascination and damnation are very close
I told you I told you that you know if
you were only in on passion bucket my
audience was right there with you and
you were and I received a lot of love
online all right you know some some odd
looks but a lot of love online well I
don't like the fact that a lot of people
were in on this joke the women didn't
know what it was you know that that
reaction you know those who aren't
watching or listening to our show I
think you you got roughed up a little
bit there with your passion bucket so I
apologize I like the look on Jason and
Molly's face who are friends of mine
when I said it there was this real half
second glimpse of what what yeah okay
we're just gonna go with it
all right recap night Wow I mean where
do you start that was there was a lot of
stuff shoved into that show you know oh
the re situation with Becca was
interesting you know she obviously was
kind of over the whole thing but I think
the thing that will come out and I
thought was interesting was he kind of
first of all he slid into Lauren's DMS
to to hook up with her after all this
bachelor stuff ended up sliding into a
girl DM and the fact that
he kind of seemed to bridge the gap he
did the straddle of I want to make sure
Lauren's back into this before I break
up with Becca and I thought that was
interesting and he kind of admitted that
himself last night what was the awkward
moment the awkward moment honestly was
the proposal okay I said that was the
awkward moment the the audience it was a
really weird vibe last night a very
weird vibe on the live show I'm usually
really it's usually easy to read my
audience and feed off the audience and I
know where my my hits are gonna come and
my my punchlines and last night
everything was just off nobody really
knew how to act and react everything
they weren't sure if they were happy for
Arie and Lauren to be engaged and in the
proposal it was like a smattering of
applause it was it was really odd it was
a very different feel
usually the ring comes out and
everybody's gasping and applauding and
it's loud and they just there wasn't
that overwhelming love last night when
they when they proposed it was really
interesting would you rather have what
played out this this time or the
traditional hey everybody happily ever
after engagement love and no drama I
think you have to have it all and this
is what people are you know it's
interesting that people are angry and
honestly when people are angry it just
means they care and it means they're
watching and it means they're into it
and it means they relate and it struck a
chord I don't think it's disingenuous to
have a show every time where you just
have this beautiful proposal on a beach
and everybody lives happily ever after
it's just not life that's not the way it
goes
and one thing I love about this show is
it's never been predicated on the fact
that it guarantees success that's that's
not realistic and so I think you have to
have the good with the bad and sometimes
it's not pretty and and I'm I still
stick by the decision to show that and
you know everyone was a little up in
arms I'm still getting beaten up by I
know you showed this and I said well you
can't just show the happy stuff it's
just not how the worries
what I didn't understand that was the
real in reality and you were showing
that and then you get criticized because
you're actually showing something that
doesn't feel like it's staged they're
scripted or you know that they you know
the Canon that feels like cameras are on
you that's what I loved about it I'd
love to see more of that stuff look the
people that yell the loudest or those
that watch the most and so I'm never
really worried about about the criticism
and as long as we've done something you
know I believe in and I can stand up for
and I do I believe in that and yeah
sometimes it's raw and it's personal and
it's too much but that's again they know
that they signed up for this they know
they're on camera and you know I I like
the real raw stuff and I'd like to see
how re reacted and how Beckett handled
herself because I and in all honesty
it's what made her and what will make
her a great Bachelorette she's so in
that moment she showed grace and dignity
and poise and yeah she was sad but I
thought she held herself together is a
very strong woman and she's going to be
a great Bachelorette so the reason we're
all tied into her in her story now is
because of what we saw so again it to me
was all good storytelling and it was a
part of the show if I give you
over-under Ari and Lauren if I give you
like 18 months you're taking the over of
the under I'll take you over hey I'm a
hopeless optimist and romantic and I and
I I think you're honestly being why the
hell not like no wonder it's so easy
it's so easy to say no it's so easy to
say someone's gonna break up because
guess what law of averages they're going
to that your neighbor is your parents
are your friends that's that's life the
percentage of people don't make it it's
hard to make it in a relationship and
make it down the aisle and make a
marriage work I know believe me I'm I'm
not throwing any stones in this Glass
House but so I say why not why not
everyone just support him for a little
bit and see how they do and I think you
may end up with Becca again and by the
way Chris said he was gonna drop passion
bucket and he did I said that he can
host this show you wanted to you wanted
I can bring the dance to Los Angeles if
you're in New York or you want to do a
home field advantage with my man cave
here in Milford Connecticut it's up to
you so you let us know when you want to
come in and host the program we're
definitely gonna we're gonna work this
out I think some sort of road show I
would love to get out east as soon as
you guys get rid of your polar vortex we
don't make this work or we just do it at
Pebble next year we'll see we'll figure
it out okay but you if you would like to
week we can do it in New York whenever
you come in there give us a heads up and
we'll we'll make that happen maybe a
simulcast from Jim Nantz is back yo man
that was all have you been there Chris I
have not Jim Jim is a friend and he's
invited me several times when we're in
Pebble and I've never made it I've never
seen the green there you gotta go but
you know he told me the story about
getting married on the 7th green at
Pebble and now he has a replica in his
backyard it's and I just want to dive
into his wine cellar well he's got the
speakers there he's got these so no
speakers and then he'll use his phone
and uses the app and you get that
masters theme music
and so it's play it his voice though
does he call his own shots in his
backyard yeah he was doing play-by-play
while we're hitting these wedge shots
and the green is is a replica of the par
3 at the par-3 7th and then we got to go
to the wine cellar he's given us wine as
we're there Jim Jim Nantz has got it
down man he's living a pretty good life
he has he has beaten the world he has
figured it all out he's figured it out
Chris thanks and we hope to see you soon
let us know when you come this way we'd
love to have you in studio guys thanks
for the love always appreciate it and
just know that Dan nation is strong I
have heard from them all this morning
thank you Chris see you guys that's not
a Chris Harrison passion bucket for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience
channel 239 on Direct TV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]